hi
my name is sandeep gupta and i'm a
product manager in the tensorflow team
in google
today i'll talk about tensorflow
enterprise and how it can help you in
building and deploying
your ml workloads with tensorflow on gcp
machine learning is transforming every
aspect of our lives
and developers and enterprises are using
ml to build impactful solutions
that drive business value tensorflow is
one of the most widely used production
ready frameworks for machine learning
and it's open sourced by google so that
everyone can take advantage
of these powerful tools but if you are
an enterprise
trying to use ml there are some
challenges you may face
new tensorflow open source releases come
out several times a year
and you may have business reasons to
stay on an older version longer
in this case you would want that
critical patches
fixes and enhancements be available in
these older versions
second cloud provides the ability to
build and deploy ml with the performance
and scalability that cloud offers
this can be difficult as it may require
a lot of manual configuration and setup
to make sure that you get the best out
of your infrastructure
investment and lastly you expect
prioritized and trusted support
we designed tensorflow enterprise with
the goals of addressing these types of
challenges when it comes to
enterprise grade ml tensorflow
enterprise
is the gcp optimized experience of
tensorflow
it consists of three main pillars
first is performance and the ability to
handle
cloud scale data and models tensorflow
enterprise
includes optimizations to help you get
the most from your data pipelines and ml
model training
on gcp second is manageability
while solving your business problem you
do not want to spend your time and
energy
creating and maintaining the software
environment and managing all the
machines in your cluster
you just want to focus on the core
business logic of your ml problem that
matters to your business
tensorflow enterprise makes it easier to
build and run ml workloads
with these managed services and lastly
tfe releases come with long term support
which provides back porting of critical
patches and fixes
so we'll look at all three of these in
more detail now
let's start by looking at cloud scale
performance first
so with tensorflow enterprise we compile
and ship
a special build of tensorflow which is
optimized for google cloud
infrastructure
it is built on open source tensorflow
but it contains
add-ons with additional runtime
optimizations and i o optimizations
which are specific for google cloud
machines and services
to help improve performance let's take a
look at an example
so this is a code snippet that you can
use to train a model
with potentially a large training data
set in google cloud storage
cloud storage is gcp's file storage
where you might maintain
terabytes of training data as you see
this code snippet is no different from
your typical tensorflow code
written with the tf.data api except that
the path to the files
points to your gcs bucket under the hood
tensorflow enterprise
built contains optimized i o readers to
make this performant
with google cloud storage here's another
example
where we read our training data set from
a big query table
bigquery is gcp's sql based data
warehouse
where you might maintain a business
intelligence data lake
with hundreds of millions of rows in
many tables
and you might want to train your models
from all this data
here we are specifying the table to read
from
the columns to read and their data types
and several other specifications
similar to the standard tf data api and
we are performing additional
transformations
such as batching and shuffling under the
hood
optimized i o for bigquery can read many
millions of rows in parallels
into the tensors efficiently so with
these optimizations included
you can get faster throughput in your
model training
with tensorflow enterprise here is an
example
on a recommendations data set where we
see that we get about a 30 percent
higher throughput
with tensorflow enterprise optimizations
this gain in data throughput
improves the utilization of accelerators
such as gpus
because now you are no longer
bottlenecked by io
it results in shorter wall time of
training for the same accuracy
as shown in the chart on the left the
purple graph you see here
is the gpu utilization profile with
tensorflow enterprise 1.15
on one model training example you see
that it is narrower in time
indicating shorter wall time and also
attains a higher peak
indicating higher peak utilization
compared to the orange graph
with tensorflow 1.14 which does not have
these optimizations
this better i o throughput helps reduce
the cost of training
also with networking optimizations to
nickel
better performance is achieved when you
scale to large clusters of gpus
for example when training the burt large
model for nlp problems
on a 64 gpu cluster we see about a 30
speed up with these improvements built
in
so we have seen some optimizations for
better scale and performance on gcp
in tensorflow enterprise now let's take
a look at how tensorflow enterprise
makes it easy to build ml
through managed services we deliver
tensorflow enterprise through a managed
environment
these are in the form of deep learning
vm images and deep learning container
images
where the environment is pre-configured
on top of a standard linux box
and made available to you what makes
this convenient
is that it pre-installs the tensorflow
enterprise build
together with all the dependencies
including device drivers
common dependency packages and
configurations
to other services on google cloud this
means that you no longer have to think
about
installing all the right packages and
drivers with correct combination of
versions
or wrangle with all of their
configurations
and support for all google compute
engine security features
such as customer managed encryption keys
and vpc
is built in right out of the box because
these are packaged pm and container
images
you have many choices for deploying them
and using them on the cloud
to get started you pick the tensorflow
enterprise image
and the desired resources such as the
machine type and the accelerator choice
and you start the virtual machine all
with one line of command
then you can ssh into the machine that
has tensorflow enterprise installed
with all dependencies and device drivers
pre-configured
and you can start using tensorflow if
you prefer a notebook environment
jupyter lab is hosted and already
started on the vm
so you can go to the browser and start
writing code
in a notebook once you have a
satisfactory model
after running some experiments now you
can train your model with the full scale
of your enterprise data it may not fit
into one machine
and you may want to take advantage of
distributed training
for large scale of data and models
gcp's ai platform training is a managed
service
for serverless training that takes care
of distributed training clusters
and provisioning of compute resources
more importantly it drives the same
tensorflow enterprise container
which has the same environment as you
have developed the model with
so you can be confident that your model
just trains
with the full scale of data on ai
platform training
here we see an example of how to do this
you create a custom container starting
with a tensorflow enterprise base image
overlay this with your model training
code
then you issue one command to start
serverless training on gcp
in this example we are using 10 workers
for our distributed training cluster
with 8 v1 v100 gpus attached to each
this brings up the distributed training
cluster with tensorflow enterprise
optimizations included
very soon cloud ai platform training
will use these tfe images
as the default runtime so you will not
have to import
a tfe container manually as shown here
now that you have trained your model in
full enterprise scale
it is time to make it an end-to-end
pipeline
to continue running in production this
can be done
using gcp's ai platform pipelines which
are built with tensorflow extended or
tfx
platform pipelines is hosted on google
kubernetes engine
so it can also drive the same tensorflow
enterprise container image
so that all the optimizations are still
included and you can be confident that
your pipeline
trains the same way as your notebook
code
in addition to managed training and
hosted pipelines there are other
additions that make tensorflow run
better on gcp with tensorflow enterprise
add-ons
let me show you two examples first
tensorflow cloud repositories apis
allow you to easily go from debugging
and training your keras and tensorflow
code
in a local environment to distributed
training
in the cloud to use this simply add the
tf cloud run api call
to your keras model training code it
will take care of adding the right tf
distribution strategy
based on the cluster configuration that
you provide and a training job will be
triggered
on jcp using the cloud ai platform apis
hybrid parameter tuning is an important
step in fine tuning and optimizing your
model
you can use the keras tuner api
conveniently within keras
to use hyper parameter tuning in your
model training
cloud tuner is gcp's implementation of
the keras tuner api
it is fully api compatible with grass
tuner and uses gcp's optimizer search
algorithm under the hood
to run the hyper parameter tuning these
add-ons
are part of the standard build of
tensorflow enterprise
and make your journey from offline
experimentation
to cloud scale implementation easier
now that we have seen cloud scale
performance and cloud integrated managed
services
let's talk about enterprise grade
support that comes with tensorflow
enterprise
key aspect of this is long-term support
open source tensorflow comes with a one
year of maintenance window
for tensorflow enterprise we extend that
and commit to providing
three years of support that includes
critical bug fixes
and security patches and optionally back
porting
important feature enhancements from
future releases
based on customer needs and demand this
means that you can rest assured
that you can upgrade tensorflow versions
based on your business's timelines as of
today we support both tensorflow 1.x
and 2.x with tensorflow enterprise
long-term support
here's a great example of what long-term
support can mean for you in practice
nvidia recently launched their a100
family of gpus
which brings significant performance
improvements in collaboration with
nvidia
we have updated the tensorflow
enterprise 1.15
and 2.1 deep learning vm images and
added support for cuda 11 kodi n8
and the new tensorflow 32 data format
to help your code take advantage of the
a100 architecture
these tensorflow enterprise versions are
the only official builds of tensorflow
115 and 2.1
with this support built in before this
lands in the mainline
open source releases you can become an
early user of these gpus on gcp
with these pre-built images getting
started is really easy
with this example gcloud command line as
shown here
where we create a tensorflow enterprise
2.1 vm
which supports a100 gpus you can learn
more about these gpus in our cloud
accelerator session
before closing let me share what lies
ahead
for tensorflow enterprise we are excited
to keep working tightly together
between google cloud and the tensorflow
teams
as being the creators and experts of
both we plan to provide further
optimizations and enhancements
to tensorflow on google cloud better
monitoring and debugging capabilities
to fourier tensorflow code and
integrations
into google cloud tooling we're also
looking at smoother integration between
tensorflow's high-level apis such as
kiras and the training services
as well as more managed services such as
enterprise version of tensorboard.dev
and integrated experiment management and
tracking
for a seamless and joyful developer
experience
i hope i've been able to show you how
tensorflow enterprise
can help your business use ml and
tensorflow on gcp
to get started visit this link shown
here and check out all the documentation
and resources
on behalf of the tensorflow enterprise
team i would like to thank you for
listening
thank you
you